[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es Pistazienecken mit Mandeln.
Also eigentlich sind es Mandelecken mit Pistazien.
Denn der Mandelanteil ist recht groß.
Und diese Ecken erinnern auch
so ein bisschen an meine Nussecken,
die ich vor einigen Jahren schon mal gemacht habe.
Einfach eine andere Variante
und vor allem jetzt so in der Weihnachts- und Winterzeit
wirklich super.
Denn ihr könnt sie zubereiten
und sogar ganz klein schneiden
und sie als Plätzchenvariante anbieten
oder eben etwas größer lassen
und als schöne große Mandelecke anbieten.
Die Basis ist ein Mürbeteig .
Darüber kommt eine Marmeladenschicht
und darüber dann die Nussschicht.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal den Mürbeteig.
Dafür nehme ich 250 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Backpulver,
50 Gramm Mandelmehl,
125 Gramm Butter,
100 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
zwei Eier.
Und hier habe ich noch Bittermandelöl
einfach so als Geschmacksträger noch mit dabei.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein Mandelmehl.
Das sind keine gemahlenen Mandeln,
sondern Mandelmehl ist das, was übrig bleibt,
wenn Mandeln das Öl entzogen wird.
Die sind also fettfrei,
proteinreich.
Die nehme ich auch ganz gerne
mal in mein Porridge mit rein,
schmecken auch superintensiv und richtig lecker.
Und die habe ich jetzt hier einfach im Teig mit dabei.
Als Mehl habe ich hier ein Dinkelmehl 630.
Ihr könnt aber auch ein Weizenmehl nehmen.
Oder ihr könnt einfach auch mal ein Vollkornmehl
mit dazu nehmen.
Einfach mal ein bisschen was Dunkleres
finde ich immer ganz gut.
So. Jetzt gebe ich einfach alle Zutaten in die Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt den Teig aber auch mit der Hand verkneten.
Jetzt auch die Mandeln mit rein.
Die Butter.
Die ist jetzt noch etwas kalt,
weil es ja ein Mürbeteig ist.
Salz und Zucker.
Die Eier noch dazu.
Und, wie gesagt, ein bisschen Bittermandelöl.
Nicht zu viel.
Und jetzt einfach die Zutaten kurz miteinander vermischen.
Oh! Ich hätte einen Spritzschutz nehmen sollen.
Ups.
[Musik]
So. Das war es schon.
Den wirklich nur so lange verkneten,
bis er sich einfach toll verbunden hat.
[Musik]
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Also ein richtig schöner, geschmeidiger Mürbeteig.
Ich forme den kurz zusammen.
Ich drücke den jetzt hier flach
und kann ihn kurz in den Kühlschrank stellen
und in der Zwischenzeit schon mal die Nussfüllung vorbereiten.
Kurz abdecken und ab in den Kühlschrank.
Das sind jetzt hier meine Basiszutaten.
Ihr könnt natürlich, wenn ihr sagt:
"Ich mag keine Kokosraspeln",
einfach mehr Mandeln nehmen
oder Haselnüsse noch dazu nehmen
oder ganz andere Nüsse wie Walnüsse
oder was auch immer ihr gerne habt.
Dafür verwende ich
200 Gramm Mandeln,
50 Gramm Pistazien,
50 Gramm getrocknete Feigen,
200 Gramm weiche Butter,
50 Gramm Wasser,
100 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
150 Gramm Kokosraspeln
und 30 Gramm Mandelmehl.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die Mandel,
Pistazien und die Feigen fein zerkleinern.
Das mache ich im Mixer.
[Musik]
Der Rest ist jetzt auch ganz einfach.
Ihr nehmt jetzt einfach die Butter
und gebt sie in eine hohe Pfanne oder in einen Topf.
Das Wasser kommt auch direkt dazu.
Und auch gleich der Zucker.
Und Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt die Masse schön einmal aufkochen lassen,
damit sich der Zucker ein bisschen auflösen kann.
Der Duft erinnert mich so sehr an meine Kindheit,
weil ich die Nussecken schon als Kind immer gemacht habe.
Ein altes Rezept von unserer ehemaligen Nachbarin.
Und jetzt abgewandelt.
Das war so witzig, weil die Frau Tenge,
die mir das Rezept gegeben hat,
die hat immer gesagt:
"Guido Horns hat das Nusseckenrezept bei uns geklaut,
aus meiner Familie!"
Ja.
So. Wenn dann die Zutaten kochen,
einfach die restlichen Zutaten dazu geben,
also Kokosflocken,
die Mandeln und Pistazien und die Feigen
und auch das Mandelmehl.
Jetzt muss es nicht mehr kochen,
sondern kann einfach noch verrührt werden.
Hieß der Guido Horn oder Guildo Horn?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
>> JOSH: Mh. Ich weiß nicht.
Der Name sagt mir gar nichts.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Krass!
Jetzt fühle ich mich alt.
Josh kennt Guido Horn nicht.
Heißt der Guido Horn oder Guildo Horn?
Keine Ahnung.
Er kennt ihn nicht. Das heißt, ich bin einfach zu alt.
Ich kann das nicht, wenn ich in meinem Augenwinkel sehe,
dass da noch so ein Fitzelchen
Kokosraspeln drin hängen.
Ich muss es auskratzen. Ich habe die Auskratzkrankheit.
So.
Nussmasse ist auch fertig.
Dann hole ich jetzt direkt den Teig
und es geht sofort weiter.
Also das ist echt ein cooles, schnelles Rezept,
ein toller Crowdfeeder, weil natürlich so ein ganzes Blech
auch viele Menschen satt machen kann.
Aber erst kurz aufräumen.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten einen Backrahmen,
weil der einfach schon richtig schön eckig ist.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch
eine Dauerbackfolie und ein Backblech.
Ihr könnt auch ein normales Backblech benutzen,
was bei euch im Ofen mitgeliefert wird.
Da müsst ihr nur dann wissen,
dass hier außen die Ecken eben nicht ganz eckig werden.
Aber die könnt ihr ja dann auch wegschneiden.
Ich backe das jetzt hier drin,
nehme meinen Teig.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so der typische, feste Mürbeteig,
sondern eher ein bisschen weicher.
Und den rollt ihr entweder aus und legt ihn rein
oder ihr drückt ihn einfach
jetzt mit der Hand so ein bisschen flach.
So ein Handausroller geht auch.
Den habe ich jetzt nur gerade nicht zur Hand.
Ich drücke den jetzt einfach so flach.
[Musik]
Ich meine, man kann das auch per Hand flach drücken.
Geht auch.
So habt ihr aber schneller ein gleichmäßigeres Ergebnis.
Es dauert dann nicht so lang,
wie alles per Hand so wegzudrücken.
Ich mache das Ganze jetzt allerdings so:
Ich werde direkt
nicht das Blech Maß nehmen, 32 x 37 cm,
sondern 30 x 35 cm.
Dann habe ich nämlich gleich ein
gerades Ergebnis zum Nusseckenschneiden.
[Musik]
Den Rest dann einfach noch kurz
so mit den Fingern reindrücken.
[Musik]
Ja, okay, ich bin ein kleiner Perfektionist.
Ich will halt auch, dass die Ecken hier so schön sind.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch eine Gabel,
stecht den Boden ein,
damit er beim Backen nicht aufgeht
und sich nicht so wölbt.
Es kann trotzdem mal passieren,
aber das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Man kann es später wieder flach drücken.
Aber so verhindert man das wirklich auch direkt am Anfang.
Dann streiche ich hier jetzt eine Marmelade rein.
Und ich habe jetzt hier heute eine Feigenmarmelade.
Die passt nämlich besonders gut.
Aprikose geht auch.
Aber ihr könnt auch eine rote nehmen
oder einfach, was bei euch im Kühlschrank gerade so offen ist
und vielleicht auch weg muss.
Die schön glatt streichen.
[Musik]
Und darüber kommt jetzt die Nussfüllung
– der Nussbelag.
Es ist ja keine Füllung.
Jetzt ist es ein Belag.
Außer ihr klappt das Ganze zu.
Dann wäre es eine Füllung.
Irgendwie zurzeit...
Ich weiß nicht, aber irgendwie finde ich es hier so still.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es ist so...
Ich will jetzt nichts sagen
und auch keinen Teufel an die Wand malen und keine Ahnung,
aber ich finde es so...
So ohne Störung, es kommt keiner rein.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Voll komisch.
>> JOSH: Habe ich da gerade eine Tür gehört?
>> SALLY: Ich habe auch gerade eine Tür gehört.
Das war aber nur Sarah.
>> SARAH: Was?
>> SALLY: Ich habe gerade gesagt,
es ist so komisch, es ist so still,
keine Störung, keiner kommt.
Und dann machst du die Tür so auf.
>> SARAH: Hier ist die Störung.
>> SALLY: Aber Sarah ist keine Störung.
Sarah gehört ja mit dazu.
>> SARAH: Das stimmt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Und guckt mal. Wenn ihr das dann jetzt so...
Hm?
>> SARAH: Du glitzerst.
>> SALLY: Ich glitzere?
Ja, es ist Weihnachten, natürlich glitzere ich.
Wenn ihr das schön...
>> JOSH: Glitzerst du?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht.
>> SARAH: Hier an der Schläfe ist so Glitzer.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: Ah, tatsächlich!
Hä?
Da ist ja Glitzer.
Und auf deinem Pulli ist auch ein kleiner Glitzerfleck.
>> SALLY: Hui! Wo kommt denn das Glitzer her?
>> SARAH: Links von dir steht auch ein süßer Glitzerfleck.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Wenn ihr jetzt die Nussfüllung schön verteilt habt,
dann könnt ihr sie gerne noch flach drücken.
Und während der Backzeit
– also das kommt ja jetzt so in den Backofen,
darf gebacken werden.
Danach lasse ich die Platte komplett abkühlen.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
können wir uns Weihnachtssongs raussuchen.
Also eigentlich ist es nur so ein 10-Minuten-Rezept
und Sally macht daraus so ein 1-Stunden-Rezept,
weil sie jede Schicht perfekt glatt haben will.
Aber guck, wie perfekt!
>> JOSH: Schon perfekt.
>> SARAH: Kannst du nicht ein so ein Ding erfinden,
das gleich groß ist wie das Blech,
das du nur so reindrücken musst?
>> SALLY: So einen Stempel?
>> SARAH: Ja, aber so in Groß dann.
>> SALLY: Wie so ein Burgerstempel nur so eckig und groß.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, ist das schön!
>> SARAH: Den kann man dann so ineinanderschieben.
>> SALLY: Schön!
Hände waschen, ab in den Backofen.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Platte gebacken und abgekühlt
und wird gleich dekoriert.
Ich werde aber schon mal hier die Schokolade vorbereiten.
Ich nehme jetzt Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Ich habe jetzt 225 Gramm.
150 Gramm werde ich direkt erwärmen
über dem warmen Wasserbad.
Das sind zwei Drittel.
Und ein Drittel, 75 Gramm
kommen dann gleich dazu,
sobald die hier geschmolzen ist.
So könnt ihr nämlich die Kuvertüre temperieren,
sie bekommt später keinen grauen Schleier
und wird schön fest.
Und jetzt hier das Ganze rauslösen.
[Musik]
Jedes Mal frage ich mich so:
Seid ihr schon gelangweilt, wenn ich euch
das mit der Kuvertüre immer und immer wieder erkläre?
Oder ich denke mir so:
Aber es kommen bestimmt auch neue Zuschauer dazu
und dann müssen die ja wissen, dass man
Kuvertüre oder Schokolade temperiert,
dass die eben schön wird
und keinen grauen Schleier bekommt.
Das ist immer so dieses
"Wie viel erzähle ich wie oft noch einmal?"
Ja.
Aber vielleicht guckt ja jemand dieses Video
und das ist das erste, was er von mir sieht,
und dann weiß er es halt nicht.
Deswegen.
Ja.
Guckt mal. Das Backpapier
– die Backfolie kann ich jetzt so lösen,
indem ich sie drunter wegziehe.
Darauf bitte nicht schneiden.
Und jetzt könnt ihr erst mal Rechtecke zuschneiden
und dann Dreiecke.
Und entweder könnt ihr sie jetzt ausmessen und zuschneiden
oder ihr nehmt einen Einteiler.
Ich habe da sogar einen mit zwei Seiten.
Die eine Seite hat nämlich kleine Quadrate.
Das sind dann 30.
Die andere Seite hat 20 Rechtecke.
Ich glaube, ich mache 20, dass es nicht zu klein ist.
Aber für so einen Plätzchenteller würde ich schon
die 30er Seite nehmen.
Und dann schön halbieren
und dann hat man so kleine, handliche.
Ja.
Nee. Aber jetzt mache ich sie größer.
Wollt ihr mithelfen?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Ich habe es jetzt halt komplett abkühlen lassen.
Wenn ihr mit dem Einteiler arbeitet,
dann am besten so lauwarm abkühlen lassen.
Dann könnt ihr es nämlich besser eindrücken.
>> SAMIRA: Dann darfst du jetzt Ela machen, Ela.
>> SALLY: Aber warte, warte! Nicht auf dem Rollstuhl.
Der rutscht nämlich weg.
Holt mal den Hocker für die Ela.
Komm mal runter.
Vorsichtig.
>> SAMIRA: Ela, holst du ihn kurz von drüben?
Der wiegt auch nicht ganz so viel.
>> SALLY: Und beide Hände waschen.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So.
Sieht doch schon mal gut aus, oder?
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und wenn man sie kleiner machen will,
kann man sie ja noch mal halbieren.
Aber, wie gesagt, wir lassen sie so.
Jetzt gucke ich mal nach der Schokolade.
Hast du was mit Schokolade gegessen?
>> ELA: Zwei habe ich nur davon gegessen.
>> SALLY: Aber vielleicht vorher auch schon?
Denn dein Mund ist so voller Schokolade.
>> ELA: Nein, vorhin habe ich
Pudding gegessen.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> ELA: Den hat Samira gemacht.
>> SALLY: Guckt mal.
Sobald die Schokolade geschmolzen ist,
einfach vom Wasserbad runternehmen.
Jetzt das hier reinrühren.
Also die restliche Schokolade kannst du reinmachen.
Und das auch. Ja.
Kokosfett
für den Glanz.
Komm, ich nehme mal das Kokosfett hier raus.
>> SAMIRA: Und die Schokodrops sind jetzt in der...
Also das ist ja jetzt warm, die Schokolade.
>> ELA: Ich will jetzt! Ich will.
>> SALLY: Rühren.
>> ELA: Um.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt kühlt die Kuvertüre...
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die ist ja hier so etwa 50°C warm
und jetzt kühlt sie durch die restliche
>> SAMIRA: Schokodrops.
>> SALLY: durch die restlichen Schokodrops einfach ab.
Und das sind einfach so Kuvertürechips.
>> SAMIRA: Das wollte ich gerade eben sagen.
>> SALLY: Halt. Vorsichtig.
Da sparen wir uns das Kleinhacken.
>> SAMIRA: Das Kleinhacken und das Abkühlen.
>> ELA: Machen wir das da rein?
>> SALLY: Nein,
die machen wir gleich auf die Nussecken drauf.
>> ELA: Machen wir das da da rein?
>> SALLY: Nein, machen wir nicht.
>> SAMIRA: Zum Glück.
>> ELA: Aber das schmeckt schon gut.
>> SALLY: He!
Nicht so viel essen!
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Kuvertüre perfekt und...
>> ELA: Ich esse einen echten kleinen Knochen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und entweder könnt ihr jetzt die Ecken nehmen
und sozusagen
>> ELA: Pfui!
>> SALLY: mit beiden
>> ELA: Der ist echt!
>> SALLY: Kanten hier reintauchen,
was ich echt recht hübsch finde,
aber auch ziemlich aufwendig.
Also, wenn man das dann so macht.
Zack!
Und zack!
Denn man muss im Prinzip
jede Ecke einmal in die Hand nehmen
und sie dann ablegen.
Die sind schon schön, gell?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schon schön.
Weil ich habe so eine Technik,
wo man einfach so alle auf einmal.
Ach, ich glaube, ich mache sie aber heute lieber schön.
Was sagst du?
>> JOSH: Das ist schon schön.
>> SALLY: Das ist schon schön,
wenn die so um die Ecke so.
>> SAMIRA: Zeig mal.
>> SALLY: Normalerweise mache ich es nämlich so,
– ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen –
dass ich die Kuvertüre mit dem Pinsel aufnehme
und dann hier den Bereich streiche.
Und praktisch immer einen Streifen,
also von der diagonalen Ecke bis zur diagonalen Ecke.
Und dann habt ihr mit einem Streifen
direkt so eine ganze Reihe an Ecken fertig.
Aber dann ist es nur auf der Oberfläche.
Und so machen wir es jetzt einmal um die komplette Ecke.
Komm, das machen wir jetzt.
[Musik]
Und dann könnt ihr gerne noch
ein paar Pistazien darauf streuen.
Das sieht auch superschön aus.
Und dann lassen wir sie alle aushärten.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Fertig!
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen übertrieben.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es voll schön!
An Weihnachten darf man es mit Glitzer übertreiben.
Aber so viel reicht?
>> ELA: Und es sieht auch echt süß aus.
>> SALLY: Es sieht richtig süß aus.
[Musik]
Ela?
Wer soll jetzt probieren?
>> ELA: Aline und Siamak.
>> SALLY: Dann ruf sie mal.
>> ELA: Aline, Siamak, kommt her!
>> SALLY: Soll Yoshi auch mit?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SIAMAK: Der Yoshi kommt auch mit.
>> ALINE: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Yoshi!
>> ELA: Yoshi, du kleiner Gauner!
>> SIAMAK: Hallo!
>> ALINE: Du kleiner Gauner!
>> SALLY: Yoshi!
Guckt mal, was die Ela gemacht hat.
>> ALINE: Das sieht aber süß aus!
>> SIAMAK: Oh, guck mal, Yoshi.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, mit Knochenaugen!
>> SAMIRA: Yoshi!
>> ALINE: Oh, das hätte er jetzt gern zum Essen.
>> SALLY: Oh, Yoshi, du Kleiner!
>> ALINE: Gell?
>> SALLY: Ich habe halt immer was Süßes an der Hand.
Das ist aber nicht gut für dich.
Die Mädels haben gebacken.
Guck mal!
>> ALINE: Oh!
>> SIAMAK: Extra für den Yoshi?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ALINE: Oh, wie süß!
>> SALLY: Aber das darf er nicht essen, gell?
>> SIAMAK & ALINE: Schade.
>> SALLY: Für Yoshi müssen wir mal
– wir haben doch so Leberwurstkekse gemacht.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ela, die kann er mal essen.
>> SIAMAK: Stimmt. Ja.
>> ALINE: Oh, die hat er gern gegessen.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ELA: Und die Marie.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die kannst du ihm
als Weihnachtsgeschenk backen,
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: wenn du willst.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Wir!
>> SALLY: Aber du musst halt dann die...
>> ALINE: Oh! Ist das für mich?
Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Das dürft ihr mitnehmen.
>> ALINE: Oh, wie süß!
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr so eine Nussecke probieren?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ALINE: Oh, lecker!
>> SALLY: Soll ich euch so eine geben?
>> ELA: Nimm mal.
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr beide eine oder wollt ihr sie...
>> ALINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, ich gebe dir eine.
>> SIAMAK: Ich nehme ihn einfach so.
>> ALINE: Danke schön.
>> SIAMAK: Danke schön.
>> ELA: Wo habe ich das hin?
>> ALINE: Das Plätzchen und die Nussecke.
>> SALLY: Der Yoshi hängt!
>> SIAMAK: Ja, der wird immer länger dann.
>> ALINE: Sei vorsichtig. Du musst den unten nehmen.
>> SALLY: Der hängt da so voll in der Luft.
>> SIAMAK: Ich beiße einfach so mal ab.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ALINE: Willst du mal abbeißen?
>> SIAMAK: Ja, genau.
>> ALINE: Okay. Probier du.
>> ELA: Darf ich bitte da durch?
>> ALINE: Jetzt hast du auf Yoshi gebröselt.
>> SIAMAK: Nicht so schlimm.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Wie schmeckt es euch?
>> ELA: Hallo? Kann jemand mich
>> SALLY: Gut?
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> ELA: durchlassen?
>> ALINE: So knusprig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Hallo? Kann mal jemand...
>> SALLY: Warte kurz, Ela.
>> ALINE: Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Hallo?
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ja, das sind jetzt heute keine so Haselnussecken,
sondern Mandel mit Pistazie.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich dachte, so ein bisschen weihnachtlicher und...
>> ALINE: Mega!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Echt lecker. Ja.
>> ALINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, cool.
Super!
>> SIAMAK: Das macht immer so satt auch, so eine Ecke.
>> SALLY & ALINE: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Man kann gar nicht so viel davon essen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ALINE: Aber das ist so lecker saftig innen drin.
>> SALLY & SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und ich habe gesagt, man kann ja,
wenn man so das für Weihnachten
>> ELA: Aline?
>> SALLY: oder für die Adventszeit macht,
kann man sie ja noch halbieren.
Dann hat man so kleine, wie so Plätzchen.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ALINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SIAMAK: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Also
>> ALINE: Es schmeckt lecker!
>> SAMIRA: Siamak?
>> SALLY: ihr dürft das Rezept gerne ausprobieren.
Ich glaube, wir spielen jetzt noch eine Runde mit dem Yoshi.
>> SIAMAK: Ich kann gerade nicht.
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist eh alles andere egal. Yoshi ist wichtiger.
>> ALINE: Ich esse weiter.
>> SALLY: Macht's gut!
Tschüss!
>> SAMIRA: Wann gehst du mal mit uns...
>> SIAMAK: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Und Ela, wir müssen bald
wieder Kekse backen, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Aus!
>> SALLY: Für Yoshi.
Du bist echt schon riesig geworden, du.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde das immer so witzig,
wie er so die Zunge raushängen lässt.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
[Musik]